Ngày bị một tăng tâm chính phố Sư lia có mố sẽ bỏ việc công nhận nhận nơi palestine,
tại khi họp đại huy động lý được gố sắp tới,
nhưng màn đe là bất đi nhằm thuốc đầy giải pháp hai nhận nước,
được có ai là con đường khả thì nhất để chăm dứt xung đồp y xong rên palestine.
Thủ tường, Anjani, Amadi, Cản Đệng,
về công nhận không chỉ mang ý nghĩa chính trị,
mà con thể hiện căn cách đối với Hoà Bình, Ệ Đệng và Nhân Đạo tại Cú vực.
Chúngy đón như zilên thông báo đang cân nhắc khi lượng quy định tưởng tờ,
với sự kiến công bố lập trường và thằng chính,
đồng thể này sẽ ra chung quá cạnh,
nhiều cuối xa phương tây chúng đo có pháp,
khăn đưa ra và ăn,
đã chính thức công nhận nhận nước palestine.
Dạ con rất nhiều đệng việc này cảnh nhiều nơi ổng hộ giải pháp hai nhận nước,
sẽ ra tăng xe ngay ngoại giao lên đi xa ra,
sông cũng tìm ở nguyên cơ căng khẳng,
thì chính quyền trên ở phép tiên quết phản đối,
và cho rằng điều này sẽ làm chăm trọng thêm xuống đồp.